I got 14 ads what the each 30
seconds what is going on I can't see
we all know that the best part of every
twitch stream is when chat gets out of
control how do you like to kiss the dog
with his tongue
mods Jesus this person I don't think is
ever
not use the Pokey emote in my chat he's
in here like all the time non-fucking
stop
who's Aaron Aaron Deez Nuts
what does that even mean hit the Quan
like my man Wiz Khalifa what are you
even saying my sideburn's a different
length
it's been a rough couple weeks
the guy came in my chat hello tyler1 how
about Streamwood
hello how about street with 10 people
for back to school money for Supply tip
table stream quarterback